the crew is a vast gorgeous and diverse
imagining of the United States of
America one of the biggest playgrounds
ever conceived for high-speed
exploration and MMO action driving join
countless other players on a
where you have the freedom to go in and
make your presence known
the crew spends 12 major American cities
Mountains
beaches
deserts
and virtually any folks from coast to
coast the 1900 square mile open world
map is divided into five regions each
with its own distinct flavor it's not
just pretty scenery if you can see it
you can drive there want to get
somewhere in the blink of an eye fast
travel to any location without a loading
screen in sight when you discover a
landmark you increase your ability to
level up and for the true explorers
uncover secret locations of car wrecks
where you can scavenge bars for an
exotic new ride
with the crew the open road is only the
beginning in this ever connected
experience missions can be played
collaboratively in a crew of up to four
players in go to missions tap deep into
your driving skills to speed toward a
destination before time runs out
or pick up islands scattered across the
country determine the optimum room and
go fast because when you're out of time
you're out of luck while your crew is
there to help others will be pursuing do
whatever it takes to put them in your
ear
follow your target anticipate their
every move and don't get left in the
dust your car is a weapon use it wisely
take down your mind reach your
destination in record time add precious
seconds to the cloth by hitting check
for the thrill of a fast car the rush of
winning carve the racing line and
compete with up to seven players who
dare take up the challenge but what's
going to give you an edge and access to
even more throughout the immense world
of the crew you'll find skill challenges
that enable you to build up experience
climb
escape
follow your line as long as possible
it's your time
hone your precision and flawless
level up and get the parts you need to
transform your call into a beast arrived
and of course satisfy your hunger for
speed
the crew is exploration it is action
driving at its finest but above all else
it's a world you share and with the
community of high-stakes drivers on the
road the crew is alive with possibility